[Aplausos]
[Música]
bernstein través de seis mil uniformes
entre infraestructura transportes son de
vuelos de hasta 30 veces
en the highway sexto de táim jas com fue
en el programa nation building
[Aplausos]
cuanto antes
[Música]
no ha sido uno ni dos ni tres sino
muchos los presidentes de los eeuu que
han llamado la atención sobre el
problema de las infraestructuras que
vive el país un problema amigos que
podéis creerme puede llegar a lastrar la
competitividad el futuro y sobre todo la
seguridad de eeuu mientras en asia y en
europa se invierten ingentes cantidades
de dinero en modernas infraestructuras
así como en el mantenimiento de las ya
existentes en eeuu muchas de ellas
especialmente en el campo del transporte
están que da pena verlas de hecho el
país con la economía más grande del
mundo ni siquiera está en el top 10 de
países por calidad media de sus
infraestructuras en el que se sitúan o
sorpresa sólo países asiáticos y
europeos incluso si obtiene la plaza
número 13 es más por la enorme cantidad
de infraestructuras con la que el país
cuenta que por el estado actual de
mantenimiento de las mismas o su
viabilidad futura
[Música]
amigos aunque pueda resultar
sorprendente en la primera potencia
mundial es muy normal tener que circular
por carreteras repletas de baches los
accidentes ferroviarios no resultan algo
extraño y los puentes que se caen por
falta de mantenimiento son bastantes más
de los que cabría esperar en un país con
tantos recursos económicos en este vídeo
analizamos las claves del gran problema
de las infraestructuras en eeuu y como
ahora el actual inquilino de la casa
blanca
joe biden pretende solucionarlo y ojo
porque ya se adelantó que el plan del
nuevo presidente que está lejos de ser
el plan que hubiéramos imaginado y el
plan que probablemente hubiéramos
deseado como ya sabéis todos los que nos
apoyáis en patrio porque os hemos
hablado de ello en varias ocasiones en
nuestro boletín semanal los eeuu se
enfrentan a un fuerte desajuste
presupuestario que ya está provocando
medidas como la mayor subida de
impuestos desde 1993 y con este plan en
washington no se han roto mucho la
cabeza sobre cómo financiarlo al final
del vídeo entenderéis por qué digo esto
así que estáis preparados para este
viaje por las infraestructuras de la
gran potencia norteamericana pues
arranquemos
[Música]
un abandono multimillonario en eeuu las
infraestructuras están muy mal eso ya lo
hemos dicho pero hasta qué punto lo
están pues por ejemplo si te da por
conducir por las carreteras del estado
de wisconsin ya puedes ir preparando un
buen presupuesto para nuevas ruedas y
amortiguadores porque el 81 7 por ciento
de todas ellas se encuentran en mal
estado aunque miradlo de otra manera así
tenéis pensado no sea de montar un
taller mecánico en eeuu pues ya sabéis
en qué estado hacerlo luego si te
atreves a [ __ ] un tren en el estado de
nueva jersey asegúrate antes de tener
contratado un buen seguro porque tan
sólo entre los años 2015 y 2019 hubo ni
más ni menos que 104 descarrilamientos
es decir 10,9 por cada 100 millas de
vías y si por algún casual necesitáis
pasar por encima de un puente en road
aislando más te vale llevar tu amuleto
de la suerte porque 2 de cada 10 puentes
de este estado tienen deficiencias
estructurales
amigos lo que os estoy contando son sólo
tres ejemplos pero lo cierto es que a
nivel nacional el 21 8% de los
kilómetros de carreteras y el 76 por
ciento de los puentes están en malas
condiciones unas cifras que sin duda
pues no son propias de un país
desarrollado mucho menos de la primera
potencia económica del planeta un
problema que además causa potenciales
pérdidas para la economía nacional
porque merma la competitividad de las
empresas las destartaladas
infraestructuras están dañando la
ventaja competitiva de eeuu y no sólo
eso se calcula atentos que tan sólo para
reparar a rim poner al día las
carreteras y los puentes hacen falta por
lo menos 700 86 mil millones de dólares
ojo solo en reparaciones nada de
ampliaciones ni cosas por el estilo
simple y llanamente para que estas
infraestructuras vuelvan a ser seguras y
puedan cumplir con su cometido es más si
por un instante pensasteis que antes
cuando decía que preparar 6 la cartera
para nuevas ruedas y amortiguadores
exageraba nada más lejos de la realidad
según cálculos de la sociedad americana
de ingenieros civiles los automovilistas
estadounidenses se gastan cada año 130
mil millones de dólares en reparaciones
de sus vehículos achacables al mal
estado de las vías en eso es una sexta
parte de todo el dinero que haría falta
para poner las carreteras y los puentes
al día tan solo en un año de una u otra
manera la austeridad en el mantenimiento
de las carreteras supone un gasto más
que un ahorro para muchos conductores en
forma de reparaciones y en necesidad de
mantenimientos más frecuentes en sus
vehículos
pero esto no acaba aquí si las
infraestructuras terrestres están que
dan pena las aéreas tampoco se quedan
muy atrás la mayoría de los aeropuertos
estadounidenses se han quedado atrapados
en la década de los 70 y los 80 en su
día eran de lo mejorcito pero la falta
de actualizaciones modernizaciones y
ampliaciones ha hecho que eeuu sea uno
de los países más ricos con los
aeropuertos más anticuados y
congestionados de todo el planeta de
hecho ni uno ni uno solo aeropuerto
estadounidense está en la lista de los
25 mejores aeropuertos del mundo y no es
de extrañar muchos de los principales
aeropuertos de eeuu como es el caso del
jfk de nueva york en condiciones por
pandemia están demasiado congestionado
sí claro
eso se traduce en retrasos que a su vez
significan pérdidas económicas
millonarias para las aerolíneas y una
menor calidad de servicio para los
pasajeros pero amigos llegados a este
punto la pregunta que seguro muchos os
estáis haciendo ya estas alturas es por
qué demonios es esto así porque las
infraestructuras en eeuu son tan
deficientes pues bien
houston tenemos un problema
para entender por qué las
infraestructuras de transporte
estadounidenses están tan mal hay que
hablar un poquito de política otro
poquito de historia y cómo no también de
dinero y cómo estamos en visual política
vamos a empezar hoy como no por la
política amigos en eeuu como todos
sabéis hay dos grandes partidos el
partido demócrata y el partido
republicano pues bien los dos partes
están a favor de mejorar las
infraestructuras de transporte pero un
aumento porque no se suelen poner de
acuerdo en el como cómo diantres hacerlo
y aquí el mayor problema lo encontramos
a nivel federal o sea es decir en la
inversión del gobierno central que debe
aprobar previamente el congreso los
republicanos creen que el dinero de un
plan de infraestructuras debe
focalizarse sobre todo en mejorar y
construir carreteras y autopistas para
que la gente pueda llegar fácilmente a
los sitios en su propio coche los
demócratas en cambio creen que los
fondos deben centrarse más en impulsar
una buena red de ferrocarriles y de
transporte público es el enésimo campo
de batalla en la guerra entre
individualismo y colectivismo pero
llevada quizás al ridículo mejorar las
carreteras para que cada uno pueda
llegar fácilmente a los sitios es
libertad para unos y algo insostenible y
propio del pasado para otros potenciar
los trenes o el transporte público
unos es casi un planteamiento socialista
porque supondría controlar el movimiento
de las personas y para otros es ni más
ni menos que el futuro de la movilidad
sostenible
el caso es que todas estas cosas hacen
que al final nunca haya un acuerdo
presupuestario para lanzar un plan
integral dotado con los fondos
suficientes como para arreglar y
actualizar las infraestructuras del país
y por eso como decíamos al principio
todos los presidentes lo intentan pero
al final ninguno lo consigue y ojo
porque el otro problema añadido es que
la mayor parte de la red de
infraestructura de transporte
estadounidense se construyó en un
periodo de tiempo relativamente corto
entre las décadas de los 50 y los 70 y
claro eso hace que a la hora de
envejecer pues lo hagan todas más o
menos al mismo tiempo pero aquí no
terminan los problemas justo ahora es
cuando llega el momento de hablar de
dinero amigos el mantenimiento y la
construcción de las carreteras en eeuu
puede venir de dos fuentes los estados y
entes locales por un lado y del gobierno
federal por otro este último financia su
aportación a través del conocido como
fondo fiduciario de carreteras
[Música]
este fondo se nutre del impuesto federal
al combustible que lleva desde 1993
congelado en 18 4 centavos por galón de
gasolina y 24 a 4 centavos por galón de
diésel sin embargo este modelo tiene
tres grandes problemas el primero es que
el impuesto al ser una cifra fija en vez
de un porcentaje y no haber sido
actualizado desde 1993 ya supone la
mitad de la carga impositiva real en
base al nivel de precios y la inflación
que había en ese año de 1993 el segundo
problema es que con el avance en
vehículos cada vez más eficientes y la
aparición de los coches eléctricos el
consumo de combustibles fósiles en
relación al número de vehículos que
circulan por las carreteras ha bajado
mucho y con ello también la capacidad de
financiación mediante este impuesto y
por último esto ha hecho que desde hace
tiempo el fondo fiduciario de carreteras
tenga que recibir dinero del tesoro
público es decir del resto de impuestos
al que en cantidad insuficiente y
contraviniendo además la naturaleza con
la que este fondo fue creado en 1956 que
no era otra que financiar la red
mediante un sistema que se asemejará al
pago por uso
de esta forma entre 2008 y 2010 el fondo
recibió 34 mil 500 millones de dólares
en transferencias del tesoro pero en la
práctica la mala sostenibilidad
económica de este fondo hace que cada
vez se destine menos dinero federal al
mantenimiento y construcción de
carreteras y puentes dejando a los
estados cada vez más solos en esta tarea
ahora bien de dónde sale el dinero para
carreteras y autopistas que destinan los
estados y cuánto supone este importe
pues fijaos
los estados y entes locales tienen su
propio esquema para financiar las
carreteras y autopistas que están en su
territorio en este caso lo hacen a
través de otro impuesto estatal o local
a los combustibles un recargo que se
suma al impuesto federal también
utilizan los peajes y claro si el
gobierno federal cada vez aporta menos
hay dos opciones o el estado en las
administraciones locales suben los
impuestos y los peajes o dejan las
carreteras con cada vez menos
mantenimiento y el caso es que algunos
estados hacen una cosa y otros la otra
pero si hablamos de cantidades y números
hay que decir que en total los eeuu
gastan en carreteras unos 135 mil
millones al año de los cuales
aproximadamente 50 mil corresponden a
los estados vía impuestos a los
combustibles y alrededor de 20 mil vía
peajes de tal forma que el gobierno
federal pone únicamente una tercera
parte del dinero unos 50 mil millones
[Música]
el dilema en toda esta historia es que
nadie ni el gobierno federal ni los
estados quieren tocar el impuesto a los
combustibles pero tampoco quieren
reparar las carreteras tirando de los
ingresos generales porque pues porque
eso supondría detraer recursos de otros
ámbitos así que es la pescadilla que se
muerde la cola y así es como año tras
año mes tras mes las carreteras y
puentes en eeuu cada vez están más
decrépitos y con los trenes pues pasa
algo parecido y con los aeropuertos pues
tres cuartas partes de lo mismo ahora
bien la pregunta es tiene todo esto
solución vale parece que la vía más
rápida para conseguir poner al país al
día en infraestructuras o como decía
trump de reconstruir la nación pasa por
el gobierno federal o un plan masivo de
inversión de infraestructuras no suena
mal no pues eso es exactamente lo que
empieza a hacer yo guay de la cuestión
es si logrará esta vez pues bien
veámoslo
[Música]
haremos plan otra vez
queridos amigos amigas seguro que todos
habéis visto ya esta noticia hayden
anuncia un gigantesco plan de
infraestructuras para ganar al futuro el
presidente joe biden presentó el
miércoles un enorme plan de 2,3 billones
de dólares para rediseñar las
infraestructuras de la nación en lo que
calificó como una inversión única en una
generación en eeuu os lo voy a decir de
otra forma para que quede más claro 2,3
millones de millones 2,3 billones
hispanos de dólares en un plan a 10 años
es uno de los planes de gastos más
ambiciosos de la historia del país pero
un momento antes de que digáis a bueno
pues ya está van a agregar de dinero
carreteras puentes aeropuertos y
ferrocarriles así que todo solucionado
espera porque hay letra pequeña
[Música]
lo primero que tenemos que tener en
cuenta es que de esos 2,3 billones sólo
600 21 mil millones son para
infraestructura de transporte es decir
unos 62 mil millones al año y dentro de
estos 600 21.000 millones únicamente 115
mil irán para reparar carreteras y
puentes unos 11 mil 500 millones al año
o lo que es lo mismo poco más de una
quinta parte de lo que ya aporta el
gobierno federal a través del fondo
fiduciario de carreteras así que no sé
tampoco parece un cambio tan grande y
recordáis además lo que dijimos al
principio del vídeo eso de que hacían
falta a 786 mil millones de dólares sólo
para reparar carreteras y puentes pues
10 la multimillonaria propuesta de
bailén no cubriría en una sexta parte de
lo que los expertos calculan que se
necesita
[Música]
pero eso no es todo los anticuados
aeropuertos de los que ya os hemos
hablado antes recibirían apenas 25 mil
millones en diez años y tened por seguro
que con eso no tienen y para empezar con
todas las mejoras que necesitan de esta
forma de todo el dinero del plan de
infraestructuras sólo el 6% iría a
reparar la red de carreteras los puentes
y los aeropuertos y si le sumamos los 80
mil millones previstos para la reciente
urbana de ferrocarriles amtrak a duras
penas se supera el 8 por ciento de
inversión en lo que podemos considerar
tradicionalmente como infraestructuras
de transporte
aquí ya nos parece tanto pues bien
seguro que muchos os estáis preguntando
ya a dónde va el resto del dinero pues
fijaos de los 621 mil millones para
infraestructuras de transporte bailén
quiere dedicar la friolera de 128 mil al
coche eléctrico el 28 por ciento del
presupuesto su idea es regar el país con
dinero para montar quinientas mil
estaciones de carga comprar autobuses
urbanos eléctricos y donar a toda la
flota federal de vehículos eléctricos
entre otras cosas luego también se
contemplan 100 mil millones para mejorar
la red eléctrica 111 mil millones para
mejorar las redes de agua y 100 mil más
para extender la red de banda ancha por
todo el país pero y el resto
no
hemos hablado de 210 mil millones en
infraestructuras 128 mil en promocionar
el coche eléctrico y 300 11.000 en luz
agua e internet
esto suman 600 49 mil millones apenas el
30 por ciento de todo el plan que se va
a dedicar el resto pues bien para eso
estás muy atentos a los próximos vídeos
de visual política porque vamos a
repasar el plan al completo pero por
ahora lo que sí os vamos a contar es
cómo piensa bailén pagar toda esta
enorme cantidad de dinero mira quién
quiere pagar el plan de infraestructuras
con 15 años de impuestos de sociedades
exacto tal cual como lo habéis escuchado
el eje central del plan en el campo
económico es una subida del impuesto de
sociedades- del 21 al 28 por ciento lo
que sí tenemos en cuenta el recargo
estatal colocaría a los eeuu de nuevo
como el país de la ocde y del g7 con el
tipo combinado más alto de este impuesto
un 32 con 34 por ciento en la práctica
esto implica cargar sobre las empresas
la mayor parte del coste no sé si parece
la mejor idea del mundo pero ya estamos
preparando un vídeo donde lo
analizaremos minuciosamente
el caso es que por otro lado el modelo
es considerado por algunos analistas
como una red centralización federal de
la política de infraestructuras porque
el plan prevé que sea el gobierno
federal el que decida cuánto se gasta y
en qué se gasta cada cosa algo que en
eeuu con el nivel de descentralización
que tiene pues no es nada común pero
claro a grandes gastos se necesitan
grandes excusas y en este caso la de
bailén es la supuesta creación de 19
millones de empleos para 2030 el
problema es que cuando todo este boom de
la construcción termine habrá que ver
cuántos empleos perduran en el tiempo
estimar cuánto le ha costado al erario
público cada empleo y calcular cuántos
se habrán perdido se habrán dejado de
crear o se habrán puesto en riesgo por
culpa de la subida fiscal
ahora bien llegados a este punto y ahora
que ya conocemos las intenciones del
actual presidente la pregunta qué
podemos hacernos es no existe algún
modelo alternativo que permitirá
solucionar el problema de las
infraestructuras estadounidenses sin
tener que recurrir a subidas de
impuestos masivas o centralización de
decisiones pues bien si os parece
echemos un vistazo a lo que está
haciendo australia
[Música]
australia está aplicando un nuevo
sistema de incentivos para financiar sus
infraestructuras este modelo consiste en
que el gobierno pone a la mente
infraestructuras en mal estado a
operadores privados y utiliza ese dinero
para invertir en las nuevas
infraestructuras que se necesitan en
este caso la ventaja es doble porque la
vieja infraestructura es además renovada
por el operador privado que consigue el
derecho de explotación de esta manera se
consigue financiar una infraestructura
nueva y al mismo tiempo renovar la
existente sin tener que recurrir a
grandes subidas de impuestos para más
inrri el modelo también prevé que las
nuevas infraestructuras construidas con
ese dinero puedan ser también vendidas a
privados mediante el mismo sistema así
que la idea es que el modelo recicla
dinero constantemente
no sé no parece un mal plan no os parece
sin duda esta sería una opción bastante
más sostenible y eficiente
económicamente que la explosión de gasto
público que ha propuesto yo bailé en
cualquier caso está claro que lo
concerniente a infraestructuras de eeuu
necesita que alguien coja el toro por
los cuernos lo que no está claro es que
este plan cumpla con ese propósito y lo
haga de la mejor forma posible pero
ahora llegados a este punto es turno
para ti crees que el problema de
desinversión en infraestructuras que
sufre eeuu tiene solución y si crees que
si crees que esa solución pasa por meter
dinero federal a mansalva o igual ya va
siendo hora de plantearse henos en
nuevos modelos de financiación dejando
nuestras respuestas por aquí abajo en
los comentarios y ya sabéis si este
vídeo se ha resultado interesante no
olvidéis darle al botón de like i
suscribiros a nuestro canal para estar
al tanto de todas nuestras
actualizaciones un saludo y hasta la
próxima
[Música]